alright time for another movie
retrospective just good one it was kind
of crazy when this week phantom of the
paradise yes
1974 yeah directed by Brian DePalma Paul
de Paul yeah here's the thing I never
saw this movie
Jenny showed it to me just the other
night and I was like man this [ __ ] is
awesome and I like musicals yeah and
this is kind of like to me this is like
a 70s version of repo the Genetic Opera
if you guys ever seen that one yeah it's
kind of like you know it was considered
being like a really cool rock opera for
the 70s yeah yeah and I mean like I'd
seen being as Rocky Horror Picture Show
yeah but it was like repo Genetic Opera
of its day yeah you know it was that was
real cutting-edge music back in the
seventies but it's aged real well real
Bowie ask stuff with Black Sabbath type
stuff and I don't think there was any
disco was there nothing I can remember
but there were yeah there's like some
glam rock some [ __ ] that look like gothy
like cabinet yeah after [ __ ] you up yeah
there's music the rock'n'roll surface
yeah and it was about a dude who just
gets [ __ ] over by the record industry
becomes kind of like Phantom of the
Opera or a certain way that's why they
call him phantom of the paradise
everything is a is everything is like a
play on something in this movie yeah
it's basically like Rocky Horror Picture
Show crossed with Phantom of the Opera
crossed with Faust with a little bit of
pictured or anger in there as well yeah
also Jessica Harper is in this couple
years for she was in Suspiria yeah so I
know I don't know if like Dario Argento
saw this movie it was like oh that's we
got to be Suzy Banyan yeah it was filmed
well story was good the story's good the
tone is just right for a rock opera
music was great yes I really loved the
music's every song that plays it like
man I've heard this before but no not
really
it's just that every song is well
written and it's written to sound
familiar
yeah you know you could tell that it's
there's even proto goth in this slightly
there's one so yeah one of the bands
comes on they're dressed all in black
and white with that damn
German impressionistic stuff in the back
what do they call that
that's urban Expressionism it was like
something out of cask yeah
Bauhaus used it a lot yeah know what you
know but I didn't realize until I was
reading a plot synopsis of this was that
every single time you see the band
that's the same band it's the same bad
he's just changes your name and the look
yeah yeah like they start out as like a
50s doo-wop band yeah then they're like
a surf band like the Beach Boys then he
like makes him into some and then he
makes him into this kind of glam rock
type of [ __ ] and then it was God God
yeah God and I was like oh yeah I didn't
even realize that like now the funny
thing about this movie is that I feel
like it's one of those ones that like
when it came out people were like it
didn't get it or just they thought it
was stupid or whatever which I guess
happened to Rocky Horror Picture Show as
well
the music was praised Paul Williams who
was also in this movie as the villain he
did the score and everything like that
so the score of this was actually
praised I think it was nominated for
some Oscars and maybe some Golden Globes
or something like that oh no if it won
but people just thought the movie was
weird and like incomprehensible or they
didn't really get it but I feel like
over the years you know appreciation for
it has really grown I can see that
that's I mean it's a little weird for
1974 I can see how 1974 audiences have
been like what the [ __ ] is going
I mean even though it's a pretty
straightforward story I mean I don't
think it's quite the plot is not quite
as like coherent as Rocky Horror Picture
Show I guess because that was kind of
more like a universal monster like
Frankenstein type of thing whereas this
is more like a phantom of the opera'
type of thing like a more European kind
of story but I mean basically you know
you got this songwriter Winslow leach
kind of a weedy you know kind of nerdy
guy and he has written some songs and
Paul Williams the evil record company
executive of death records yeah if
you've been dead bird and everything if
you know Paul Williams is he I grew up
seeing him everywhere
yeah everywhere the dude is like 5 feet
tall blonde hair if that he might even
be smaller he might be the size of Danny
DeVito which I think he might give Danny
Danny DeVito's probably like 410 in the
411 yeah I'm not sure but he might be
that small but he was a charming
[ __ ] Nicky could write these
songs and back in the 70s whenever you
saw photographs of him he was just
dripping with lemon he was so much
beautiful to me he was in funny and
charming and he had a lot of money he
goes a long way yeah yeah and he wrote
wrote cool songs and he was a very cool
guy he's alive to this day yeah I think
he's in his 90s now maybe yeah I got a
baby's a nice product but alive to this
day and I think he wrote most this mood
music he did yeah he does okay but he
knows how to write he's an amazing
master songwriter oh yeah he wrote a lot
of pop songs that other people took did
other people took her shirt yeah
somebody's pop to even think oh man yeah
Billy Idol wrote that or whatever now
putting up he he wrote it yeah yeah yeah
he was one of those guys who's got a
like behind like behind the scenes yeah
he'd write your songs for you and make
you famous yeah and then he and then
he'd just turn up on like yeah celebrity
exactly Hollywood Squares or whatever
yeah like he wasn't doing a star on oh
you guessed on Fantasy Island yeah The
Love Boat
you know and [ __ ] like that like it was
everywhere yeah he was he was kind of
like a secret player big player behind
behind the scenes in Hollywood and in
the record industry a music industry
which in a way I think that's was I
think that's why it was cast that was a
genius casting in this making him
essentially you know the devil because
you know the whole thing is that about a
Faustian Faustian bargain and so he's
like this evil record executive that
runs death records and he hears Winslow
leach
like performing some now Winslow leach
he just like works behind the scenes or
whatever at this club and he hears him
performing some songs and he thinks
they're great now Winslow was like oh
well this is part of like a whole can
Tata and I've got like a whole bunch of
these songs and stuff like that and so
what ends up happening is that Paul
Williams whose character's name is Swan
he's like oh well yeah I'll totally help
you out and produce
and everything but really he steals all
his music and then he basically frames
Winslow and sends him to sing sing then
he like plant drugs on a Mersenne [ __ ]
yeah which that was a little bit of a
kind of a call back to was Alexander
Dumas was he he wrote man they are masks
no no the other one
[ __ ] now I'm [ __ ] brains locked up
then drink it not that much no no it's a
yeah yeah I know and reduce what's his
name The Count of Monte Cristo The Count
of Monte Cristo so there is that Count
of Monte Cristo element where he breaks
out of prison to get his revenge but he
doesn't do it in the way money and the
count does it or he actually doesn't
kind of like the way the Phantom of the
Opera kind of does it eventually but not
really he also gets enslaved he's it's a
good story it's a good story well one
thing that happens to him too is that
while he's in prison don't they do you
like that experimental thing on yeah
pull all his teeth no his teeth and they
give him like these metal metal like
silver teeth Frankenstein monsters yeah
and then like while he's escaping from
jail and while he's breaking into death
records and stuff like that like this
like ridiculous set of circumstances
that like he gets smooshed in a record
press voice he loses his voice like all
this other kind of [ __ ] happens so he's
like all deformed so he has to go like
the Phantom of the Opera route and he
puts on like this silver like the very
iconic like silver Matt it looks kind of
like a bird I guess yeah and then with
he's over teeth sticking on anything the
[ __ ] do to the devil the guy who owns
death records puts on kind of like a an
amplifier and a microphone and hooks a
mountain gives him kind of like a
cybernetic voice yeah a lot of
distortion in it so his way he sings
this [ __ ] crazy kind of dust really
though it's a good idea and I have to
say - it's like obviously we were
talking about Jessica Harper's character
now before all of this horrible [ __ ]
like happens to Winslow
while Winslow still thinks that Swan has
his best interests at heart and that
he's gonna give him money to buy all
these songs and everything like that so
he but when he comes back to death
records he finds that Swan is
auditioning all these girls like for
this
musical or the can tada that he's gonna
perform like to open his club the
Paradise and he hasn't told Winslow
about any of this so Winslow is kind of
upset but he gets to talking to Jessica
Harper's character and um whose name is
Phoenix and when she sings like when she
tries out um
Winslow determines he's like well she's
the only one that's gonna sing my
material so that's very Phantom of the
Opera where it's like he only wanted
that one woman to like sing his stuff
and anybody else that did it was gonna
die so there was that whole aspect also
um I love and like I said it's another
kind of like kind of similarity the
Rocky Horror Picture Show is like when
they have one of the later bands I think
they're called the undead's yeah like
when it when they go like the goth
glamour out the he wants to get this
band together to sing some of the songs
and for the lead singer because he says
oh yeah we're gonna let Phoenix the girl
we're gonna let her be the lead but then
he like sticks her in the back Hills
like the background singer and then he
gets like this this like kind of hunky
guy like like Rocky Horror like the
monster in Rocky Horror kinda except
like even more over-the-top like to the
crazy curly hair like big-ass very
familiar and his name is beef beef yeah
and he just has these great like rubbery
facial expressions and it's just like
super Fanta yeah it's like kind of
muscular and big and in good condition
he'd sing like [ __ ] crazy I don't
know who that actor is but then he acts
gay as health he's like really
effeminate and gay with yeah but he's
also masochistic you see is kind of like
pansexual in a way but it's yeah but it
was a glam rock that was just the wait
glam rock was back of this oh yeah that
was actually spot on spot on character
for the Thais yeah that's how they were
yeah it's a good movie man I liked it it
really again yeah it's like and like I
said you know we saw it come up on
shudder
yes I'll shatter and I actually haven't
seen it and I had seen it in a really
long time talking shudder for free again
well it was that's why we ended up doing
this because this I don't even know if
this was on my list or not but when I
by I'd like remember I can't believe I
didn't see this I can't believe it
either
I mean it was okay if you liked the wall
Pink Floyd the wall you'd like it if
you'd like if you liked Greece you'd
like it it's trying to think what else
musical if you liked the repo Genetic
Opera you'd like it um what else would
you say in terms of musicals that this
would compare with it's just any kind of
like weird me like if you'd like to UM
watch these Xanadu again yeah oh
definitely it might be like Xanadu I
remember as an Adu as a kid
me not really liking it that much but I
probably would like it now you probably
would and going a little bit newer um if
you like stuff like velvet goldmine yeah
you're gonna dig in the Angry Inch know
you probably dig this it's like I said
it's kind of like it's Brian De Palma
and it's very much Oh style like all
over it okay sergeant pepper's Lonely
Hearts Club Band oh my god I treat
heroin we have to do Sergeant Pepper
this is much better than Sergeant Pepper
sergeant pepper's actually shitty but
Sergeant Pepper was an awesome watch
because it was just kind of like
watching music video after a music video
didn't really have story to it but I
like it kind of did kind of but they
were bullshitting you they were forcing
a story into that yeah it was just the
most tenuous yeah links between like ass
how can we write a story that kind of
incorporates all of these beetles yeah
it sounds like it goes like a story but
you know what I like sergeant Pepper's
you know what I saw that when I was a
kid and I must have seen that thing like
400,000 times into the Bee Gees in case
you didn't know it's the Bee Gees are in
it and Aerosmith is in it raisins in it
awesome
yeah so but it's them doing like Beatles
songs and they'd kind of like made this
flimsy story like and as objectively
shitty is that movie is yeah I love that
[ __ ] movie you know what I mean the
movie see what when you were in your
high yeah it is there's something really
comforting about or there's something
really you know I mean it's it's like
grease - it's like I know it sucks I
know it's a bad movie yeah but I love it
I can watch it over and over again and
ever
pretty swans a masterpiece on there but
on the other hand the grease one was the
best oh yeah I never said that and then
that live grease that they did I have
that on blue Braille some of the live
television I did a grease that thing was
awesome
last thing I thought was better a belt
had boys 2 men that did the yeah one day
and yeah
beauty school dropout although I heard
they did the same thing that Fox live
thing they did version of Rocky Horror
Picture Show but I heard it wasn't good
whoo yeah they did the same I don't know
if it was the same cast or not but it
was like a similar type of thing it was
like a big event and everything and I
saw it was coming up and I was like oh I
should watch that but then like
everybody I knew that saw it was like I
always so bad that makes us so ingrained
in people
well there were a lot of - well you know
what that there was a lot of changes
that they did in Greece but well true
but the changes mean since Greece the
movie is a lot less sleazy yeah yeah
then the original stage but it's a good
version the casting I thought was better
because you know Danny in the in the
movie of course was what's-his-name
Scientology John Travolta but if you
look at job to job revolt erupted
throwing his weight around like he's a
thug abut you look at Johnny's there's
nothing to him
yeah scarecrow you know but they cast a
new guy on the new Danny on there and
then he did look like he could yo his
fists you know they're mean I feel like
it is you know what would have been good
I feel like even if I think john travolt
I like John Travolta in grease but I
feel well yeah he's great he's a great
dancer oh yeah and I like him in the
movie I'm not saying that but in a way I
almost wonder if it would have been like
if the guy that played Kenickie played
him Oh what it made more sense to me I
love the handy-dandy role that's what I
make what if what if that had happened
yeah it might not have worked out I
don't know most be Kenickie that
actually did the race but they but job
change that up because he's like no I
know I'm the star I have to do
everything it made more sense though in
the movie
well yeah true like I said they made a
lot of changes Jane took a lot of
musical numbers out and said I like that
for the musical it was
all-star cast basically every member in
the cast was a Beijing
you know them in there they had like a
feature cameo yeah for the movie you had
a stream line that down into main
characters and supporting characters
yeah yeah I mean it doesn't the the
stage is not the same as film
well yes I understand why they did like
I said you have to you have to make
change from Brad's form I mean we talked
about that a lot specially when
something's being adapted from a book to
a movie it's like [ __ ] same work same as
stage musical yeah it's not gonna work
the same right and it's just like a
different format you know that's what
happens
but yeah phantom of the paradise like
some couple a little fun facts about it
did you know one of the or the set
dresser on this movie was [ __ ] Spacek
okay would two years later being Brian
De Palma's Carrie yeah so you know I
always thought she was just cute for
some weird reason you know Manfred she
is just cute herself there wasn't really
anything you could really point out of
then she was little and skinny but had a
pretty face design about well I've
always kind of liked kind of ghostly I
would have more interested in
interesting looking people than pretty
looking we don't go you know what I mean
because sometimes well sometimes like um
you know cuz I watch a lot of horror
movies and stuff and like sometimes I
watch a lot of ones that like went you
know directed Netflix order because some
of them are good but some of them not so
much or they're just generic um I feel
like a lot of the actresses and actors
too that are like in there that are like
in their 20s and stuff I can't tell one
from the other
yeah well just because I don't know if
it's just because that's the specific
look that they go for cuz that's like
what's a good looking now or if they all
go to the play same plastic surgeon or
what but it's like a lot of them but I'm
just like okay now which blonde chick is
this now it's like that oh you know I
mean they all they're interchangeable so
I'm always kind of I always kind of like
people that are like attractive but also
kind of weird-looking yeah because
they're more distinctive you know you
know immediately who yeah although there
there are some classically beautiful
women to me that just kind of have stood
out oh yeah the Great's of all ties oh
yeah if you ask me in the history of
people that have been photographed and
recorded of how they look probably the
best looking woman of all
time I'm gonna say was probably Barbara
Eden she was a very good wrong this is
my taste you didn't like if you were to
say which one of these is private is
that probably the best of it and there
are a lot of good-looking women well
there are the differences between them
all is really just preference or what
your your opinion is yeah you know so
that's not an absolute you know maybe
but to me I would say although you know
you could almost say that and Holly
would recognize this to Elizabeth
Montgomery was close to that yeah
you know I mean they were competitors on
two different channels at that's time to
get people to watch bewitched and and I
Dream of Jeannie they did kind of pink
willing to kind of looks kind of similar
in a way yeah that was kind of like what
was yeah I would still price a some
people would go but you know
well of course damn what's her name the
the blonde bombshell of all times
Marilyn Monroe that's right people gonna
say Marilyn Roe but I don't really see
much I didn't I don't see what they're
talking about
I mean she's not a woman but she's not
sometimes too I think you had to see
them in action back in those days
sometimes yeah they photographed well
and stuff but I think a lot of what made
her attractive was her persona like in
movies and things like that I think
people that was what people's play and I
think that kind of came across with
maybe somebody like Betty Page or
somebody like that
who like if you look at it it's a
context oh she's not beautiful but in
the context of the time I think Betty
Page is beautiful but um but in the
context of the time just because she was
so fresh-faced she was like girl next
door she was beautiful but not
unobtainable and there was something
like kind of charming about her too like
she was always kind of smiling and she
always looked happy so I think that it's
not just how somebody looks yeah it's
sometimes you know no you know I
probably say that still probably to say
Barbie debry had it although Jun nation
you know it's weird it's like and I
don't know why I just thought of this
out of rain cuz I've you know I've seen
a lot of like kind of you know
attractive women in movies and stuff
like that but for some reason one of the
most like ridiculously beautiful women
Isabelle Adjani and especially no and
especially in the nos Bharati remake oh
okay yeah when I saw that movie
and also possession like when I'm like
oh my I'm like just stop it she's like
it's ridiculous like she's like perfect
she is like a pearl she's perfect
that that girl that I met with that girl
that you pointed out to me from the
tenant what was her name that actress
with a big big glasses yeah that's her
that's her same one yeah okay yeah and
we agree
she was pretty stunning yeah and even in
the tenant like she kind of had the
frizzy hair in the big guys you can
really see her right like when you see
her same one in her full thing like in
nos yeah like in nos rots you and stuff
you're like holy [ __ ] she's gorgeous
very different from st. Barbara Eden
yeah different style and everything but
I can't understand yet they both had
impact yeah yeah also the woman that
played Morticia Addams on the original
yeah okay I thought she was when I was a
kid I thought she was the most beautiful
woman that ever existed although you
live on DeCarlo now we're talking about
women well speaking of women getting
back to Phantom in their days Jessica
Harper is in this who I think is also
quite beautiful and like I said I'm
interested if Dario Argento saw her in
this and wanted to put her in Suspiria
because she has this real she has this
real quality about her that I think
Dario wanted as well because you know in
Suspiria he wanted to be like Snow White
and everything she has this real
doe-eyed innocence so like you want to
protect her you immediately want to like
protect her she's just that kind of she
she just like radiates that kind of
thing and she definitely does in this
too so I think she's kind of like
perfectly cast she's got this big huge
eyes and you know just that that sweet
looking face and so I think she was like
really well cast in this too so I
mentioned the [ __ ] Spacek thing that's
how we got off on that whole thing yeah
so yeah so this movie like I said it got
released in the US on actually on
Halloween of 1974 and promptly flopped
like I said I don't think they got it
now in the end of his time yeah yeah a
lot of movies are I mean the [ __ ] man
John Carpenter's The Thing Falacci when
it came out so I can't I'm gonna go back
and kick people didn't know how to movie
back then 98 OU's ass 81 everyone a lot
of great movies fly
I mean they're just because they just
well these aren't ready for him well the
thing is it's like sometimes a movie
comes out and it's like everyone just
immediately recognizes that was a great
movie yeah extra Wars oh no Mad Max fury
road yeah
read more recently everybody like pretty
much 99% of people like yeah that was
[ __ ] awesome
some people hate that movie you know I
mean because those I think there's like
gender politics in there I I see what
they're talking about it wrong but I
have to actually kind of squint to see
what they're talking about if you ask me
too many that's to me that moot the
storyline of that movie in the gender
politics in that movie come on that was
about like what the other Mad Max movies
were made that complained didn't see the
other Mad Max movie yeah there was yeah
because it was very similar there were
always warrior women in the in the Mad
Max well and he was always kind of like
a sideline here yeah it was never really
the main character really his origin
story was the first one and it wasn't
even really the main character in that
I've never seen actually goose yeah was
the main character until Matt until max
rose to the occasion to avenge Guth's
brain burned up yeah now the big mistake
was is that you know in a road warrior
humongous Lord humungus really was
supposed to be goose goose burned up
basically turned from the dark side and
he was supposed to get max will join me
and my armies oh that would have been
awesome yeah that would have been
awesome I guess they figured well maybe
people didn't see the first movie look
at that out but you know it's you know
these movies are much deeper than people
think they are now so much not so much
Thunderdome even though I'm not gonna
[ __ ] on Thunderdome it is a Hollywood
movie it's got a Hollywood tone to it I
still like it but really Road Warrior is
deeper than a lot of people think it is
just a lot of subliminal messaging in
road warrior yeah but you know the point
I was trying to make is that sometimes
you know sometimes movies come out where
people recognize their greatness of
meanness you know Indiana Jones you know
or Raiders of the Lost Ark rather Back
to the Future you know stuff like that
but then there are some movies like the
thing like some some that are maybe
like not like a little weird okay from
New York it took a lot of people to get
yeah you know I think that but you know
eventually people kind of catch up to it
so sometimes I think they're kind of
ahead of their time this one I think
maybe was too I think there was a lot of
kind of [ __ ] like some like parody kind
of stuff going on in it and like all
these sort of references to older works
and I feel like people just didn't get
it and Brian DePalma was a little bit
out there anyway even though he kind of
got really successful later on like he
had kind of had his own style which was
sort of Hitchcockian but it I'm gonna
talk to my gun freaks real quick
in this movie a weird-ass American gun
makes a cameo the [ __ ] the phantom
when he shows up at one time towards the
end rescued his revenge with a weird-ass
[ __ ] gun I don't know what it's
called but it was an American 45
semi-auto blowback operated carbine I
guess we would call it just like a
mac-10 but it was a tubular body in
mounted inside a wooden stop kind of
like a rising rising the submachine gun
world war ii kind of like that but it
had a cone flash suppressor on it and
the damn [ __ ] optics on the top
that's the scope it was a bizarre crazy
ass thing if you can idea I used to know
the name of it but I forgot if you could
ID that thing drop drop a comment in the
comment section what gun that was hokey
is [ __ ] gun of all times there
supposedly pretty good pretty reliable
heavy you know probably originally like
a blowback submachine gun like a mac-10
communi but it was converted to
semi-auto that's enough of the gun [ __ ]
I know we got fans that love that [ __ ]
if I remember correctly had cooling fins
cut into the chamber end of the barrel
inside a wooden stock it was just a
bizarre a second gun he tries he tries
to assassinate somebody misses the shot
hits the priest instead you'll see it I
mean yeah I mean everything about this I
mean specifically they probably want a
scar B you know because it was like over
the top everything about this is over
the top like I said now what I thought
was weird and what I was kind of getting
at with you know it flopping and not
people not appreciating it weirdly
enough there was one market where even
back in
for it did really well and that was in
Winnipeg Manitoba Canada for some reason
people there [ __ ] loved it it opened
on December 26 1974 and it played in the
movie theaters in Winnipeg for four
months and the soundtrack it's like good
taste some nice ahead like change that
one place isn't that funny it's like I
wonder what was going on in Winnipeg at
the time where it was like oh yeah this
this is it right how much I bet there
were no well how much one bet there was
like a bunch of like fans for fans of
[ __ ] musicals and like what was Rocky
Horror yeah I bet did a Rocky Horror
thing
well I can't watch it played for four
months and they said even like
periodically after that like in the 90s
they brought it back into theaters and
it was like really successful in the
2000s they brought it back into theaters
and it was really successful to go they
shattered an IMAX yeah the music is
amazing and like I said even at the time
even people that didn't care for the
movie
the soundtrack did pretty well and the
soundtrack was also up for you know
Academy Awards and stuff like that so
people did recognize that the music was
great which it is you like 70s Bowie and
seventies flash yeah you're gonna glam
anyway I don't like that and like I said
it's just ridiculous it over the top it
just has this really awesome you know
kind of an Iggy Pop vibe to someone
yeah just like it's like I said really
ahead of its time unless especially if
you like any kind of like Rocky or any
kind of like weird yeah musicals like I
said like head big or anything like that
you would probably really really dig
this if we ditch again I will see a
drunk we weren't drunk when we watch
again probably I mean I couldn't Bend
that was right about halfway I was like
I could have been that drunk cuz I ain't
like remember it really if I'm too drunk
I'm just like that I haven't watch that
that's a good thing about it musicals
that they're rewatchable
oh yeah we popped in we pop in Greece
every now and then I never just listen
to Greece and then she just let Greece
to play does it okay I put that on
because we have
and then he's like I said I know it
sucks and in a way when we were watching
phantom of the Paradise and we were
talking about sergeant pepper's Lonely
Hearts Club Band which was directed by
Robert Stigwood by the way which I saw a
million times when I was growing up and
I told I was like and I think I was a
little bit drunk at this point when I
was like we needed by that blurry - if
they have it on blu-ray I don't know
yeah it's like it's like it's a terrible
movie I don't know I know it's a
terrible terrible but it's anybody yeah
action of videos yeah basically
basically there are music videos of cut
of Beatles cover songs by 70s hits
yeah 70s they've got Aerosmith singers
mem together in it that's right it's got
it's great house Cooper's on Alice
Cooper's in there I actually honeys I
liked that one well the Bee Gees are the
main character the characters their
sergeant pepper's whatever it is
whatever it doesn't make any sense no it
doesn't but like I said mustard and [ __ ]
yeah it's seriously just like you know
[ __ ] don't try to think just just
watch it take some acid and watch the
[ __ ] you don't think about you will have
a wonderful time it's just like you know
it's Beatles music so it's good you
can't mess it up I can't mess this [ __ ]
up I know every one of those songs
yeah and just show you some weird-ass
imagery and they try to make those songs
into a story yeah and there's Burns's
enjoys birds in it is God he's always
God I'm gonna say now that
motherfucker's God as in be always
played at being for the benefit burns
owe it to me is always God well known oh
god he's every time I see George Burns
when I go to heaven and die
it better be George Berger God will take
take the form of George
probably everybody that grew up in the
same era that we grew up and watch the
same TV is us I kind of feel like yeah
yeah people younger than us I think God
will probably be Morgan Freeman will be
God well they will be God for like you
know Millennials and one but I think
Generation X in before us yeah George
Burns is God because they're like right
at the end of because you know George
Burns was in his 90s when we were
watching - yeah yeah so cigar got big as
ears and he lived for such a long time
hundred and something years old when he
her some late 90s I think he almost made
it almost made so hundred yeah yeah I
think he was 99 they put him up on a
Tonight Show and he'd lose track of what
was going on and they'd have to like
they'd head to like flat track at a
laugh track his ass off the strange yeah
okay okay okay George okay you had to
watch it with George cuz he couldn't
keep it he couldn't keep his [ __ ]
together those last two or three years
well [ __ ] man Blake is 90 something
years old I mean you get to 99 years old
I think you've you know you've earned
your right to just like not know what
the [ __ ] you know I'm having his
birthday that's right Johnny Carson did
have them all from birthday you know
what's funny kids didn't grow up with
Johnny Carson The Tonight Show with
Johnny Carson that show there's
something about that show that show will
stand for the test of time and that's
that's a talk show well and you know he
was the lord of Hollywood in those days
you know what's interesting is that when
on our matinee show last year we were
talking about the movie I am mother yeah
significantly the daughter character and
that was watches old Johnny Carson guys
like on her thing Johnny never explained
why really but Johnny Carson was
basically the grand moff tarkin
if he said you were good then you were
good and you made it if he said you
sucked you would never make it yeah he
ran that show he probably did I think he
did he was just like he was like that
little person that's like behind the
glass wall and I ran dry yeah he was on
runs everything he was on yeah or like
the man behind the curtain yeah yeah
yeah but yeah okay so get it this was
[ __ ] all over the place well the
musical so where you have we can take
liberties yeah okay that's his story
exactly do it yeah yeah so phantom in
the paradise like I said if you're into
like weird musicals if you're under
Rocky Horror and you haven't seen this
if you're gonna like early Brian DePalma
um you know this is kind of a little bit
weird for him but not that weird I guess
he had some strong director yeah he had
some crazy [ __ ] out there but yeah check
it out it's on shudder at the moment and
that will do it for this latest version
of the retrospective are we not gonna do
the love [ __ ] they know how to get ahold
of us alright so like I said patreon
blah blah blah you guys know that we're
not gonna do it anymore cuz you guys
said yeah [ __ ] out of here the